One of the most infamous cases of a drug being introduced was thalidomide and
Thalidomide,
uh,
was,
was used for morning sickness story and pregnancy,
primarily in Germany.
A little bit in,
uh,
in the UK.
Uh,
it was introduced in Germany in the 50s,
was used widely at least until the mid sixties.
Um,
and so,
um,
it's estimated that somewhere between 7,000 to 10,000 children were born with
dramatic,
a malformation of,
of limbs,
uh,
so called thalidomide babies.
This is the difference between,
uh,
the Terada Gin and the morning sickness drug that one bond,
cause you remember a in three dimensional space,
a bold a bond is coming out toward the,
toward you in three dimensional space and a dash bond is going away from you in
three dimensional space.
Merely the orientation of the,
uh,
of that one bond means that this one does,
does not fit into the DNA major groove.
If you imagine the grooves of the double helix,
and it's fine,
it's a great drug for morning sickness,
but here,
because it can't fit into that groove,
it brings about,
uh,
genetic mutations,
which,
which make it act as a birth defect agent.
Um,
so,
and when this was originally produced,
it was produced as,
um,
what's called a racemic mixture,
meaning that both are made at the same time and equal proportions.